we're running out of time you've seen
what's happening out there
odd
[Music]
I can handle Thomas he'll show up
eventually that's what I'm afraid of
they took you because you're immune
- a plague that's wiping out the human
race they think you're worth sacrificing
to find a cure we'll never stop moving
stop them the last city click explode
base of operations mr. meyen standard
model extra we're going three years we
spent behind wolves trying to break out
now we're trying to break back in all
right I guess shotgun
the world is dying
if we find a cure that's the only way
all this was worth it bureaucrats are
you just hush I did what I thought was
right
there's no guarantee we make it back for
you don't we stop this together as well
end it that way too
you still care about it not to lie to me
annotates believe the roundup and
torture kill when the hell does it stop
it stops when we find a cure
[Music]
Thomas you can save your friends or you
can save us all
[Music]
please to me
[Music]